los beneficios de las inversiones En gas
natural cuestionados el programa para el
medio ambiente de la ONU emitió un
informe dirigido a los países de América
Latina y el Caribe este advierte de que
invertir en gas natural retrasa a
implementar renovables agrava la crisis
climática y puede convertirse en un
activo varado estos avisos se producen
después de que el organismo haya visto
que en países como Argentina Panamá y
Granada el uso del gas natural aumentó
desde la patronal regional energética lo
justifican cuando hablamos de las
disrupción que ocurren en Ucrania se
pone énfasis a la seguridad energética y
mucha gente pensó que la transición
energética se dejaba de lado pero como
dije no es una típicotomía lo que ha
pasado con la con este crisis que
tenemos en este momento es que se cambia
el ritmo pero no el rumbo de la
transición energético Pero según el
informe de la ONU los beneficios
económicos de la sobre el gas natural
son tres veces superiores mientras que
los puestos de trabajo para 2050 serían
85 veces mayores y la reducción de
emisiones es cuatro veces superior en el
sector eléctrico que en el gas natural
gustahumanez subdirector del programa
para el medio ambiente de América Latina
y el Caribe de la ONU pidió en Francia
24 continuar con los esfuerzos y ahí
vemos Que a ese largo plazo sí que
tienes una reducción sustancial lo que
pasa es que esto va a depender de que
todas estas políticas inversiones y
compromisos se pongan en práctica que
los países verdaderamente no den Un paso
atrás Después de la pandemia y la guerra
en Ucrania los mercados energéticos se
han visto perturbados agravándose la
triple crisis de cambio climático
contaminación y pérdida de biodiversidad
desde la ONU consideran imprudente tomar
decisiones energéticas con una visión a
corto plazo